[Music]
all righty frenemy's second app of the
week
because we were we were uh chatting it
up too much in the first one
and it's higher cpms in december say
what higher cpms this month
oh higher cpms episodes that's why
people do vlogmas right because oh
vlogmas
rack up the should we do vlogmas here it
is every day yeah i mean
they say they'll watch anything i'll you
guys want to watch us eat cereal or
whatever but we'll make money here
this might be the worst episode because
i just don't think my audience
definitely doesn't care about beauty
stuff
your audience definitely doesn't care
what you're doing it's not about the
beauty stuff
per se it's about how ridiculous it is
and how much you know our reaction to it
i don't think people are looking
for beauty products to buy tricia yeah
but i don't think this is interesting
it's not 2012 youtube you know what i
mean like beauty's not popping like it
used to be
but well if you have any ideas for the
podcast i'm all ears cause we're out
here
you know what i mean like we're trying
abs put all this together i don't know
if you could see
yeah okay pizza hut just came out with a
triple treat box
you want to eat pizza with me yeah i
want you want to cancel this and get a
pizza because i'm down
just give me the word you're actually
down aren't you yeah because we're
talking about how we can only eat one
meal okay
so your idea for a video is to eat pizza
with me yeah
the treat box it's a triple treat box
it's stacked like this it's pizza
it's pasta and it's dessert you think
that's a good podcast idea
yeah okay maybe i'll get lit i'll stay
in control
it's only it's only here till holidays
to like the christmas i mean hanukkah's
you want to do a third episode of us
just eating pizza
honestly december baby let's go
dan pulled up dan put up a box oh calm
down jesus right so wait there's a pizza
on top
a pizza in the middle and desserts on
the bottom the triple threat
oh triple treat more like the triple
bypass
box oh my god i got pizza
do you think we could finish that
between the two of us i could finish it
myself
no you couldn't yeah because when you
were on last time i crushed the whole
pizza and you're like oh my god i'm so
impressed
oh i was trying to be like skinny like
you know the first time you go on like a
date with someone you're like don't want
to eat all your food
you were just telling me you cried
because you had one chicken nugget the
other day
that's my eating disorder i'm like a
binger i binge or i don't eat it
i don't want to enable you but i have to
eat it's not binging if we have a piece
of
yeah but you've got to eat healthy you
can't be like okay my meal for the day
is the triple threat box
the triple bypass i had a set i had i
had just chicken breasts yesterday you
can ask them this all i had was a
chicken breast and that was it
yeah but that's not healthy because you
go i'm gonna have a chicken breast
and then tomorrow i'm gonna have a
triple threat first of all it's between
the two of us and i think it's for two
people so it's fine
how much is it dan this is not sponsored
by the way
it should be pizza can be sponsored why
don't we have fast food sponsors we
would
oh that doesn't sound right that's too
much food for 21 bucks
that's total that sucks dude it's not
that much
i think it should cost more i'm
concerned about what i'm putting in my
body it's only 21
you can really order that right now make
it happen
yeah we'll probably be here by then
order it now we'll have it by the end of
the episode we're doing intermittent
fasting we'll do it
yeah it's our one meal don't worry about
it we're gonna do a beauty product
all over our faces and then we're gonna
destroy our bodies with pizza hut
the triple can i just say i have bad
news what pizza hut does not deliver to
this
address who can we send pick it up oh my
god
moses moses that's the only person
you're going to take one for the team
i don't know he's down he's not again
wait really
oh you want to get on the trail we need
two triple threats because there's
supposed
you wanted you went onto the triple
threat should we shoot maybe he's in
let's get not three calm down
one four you guys want you guys don't
want two between the two of you not as
crazy
we'll have one triple threat for us for
the show one for them okay that makes
sense
all right get two triple threats all
right hey stop are we gonna see the
biggest in the room are we
do we weigh the most are we the two
heaviest in the room right now i would
say without a doubt
dan how much do you weigh i don't
because you're tall that's i don't think
you're fat you're just tall
i'm like 180 190. what are you yeah you
told me you're like 200.
i'm like 210. 210. you know damn
you are the triple threat in the whole
[ __ ] package
i'm a big believer it's like not about
what you weigh though because i don't i
think i look pretty good i mean
no i mean some people i mean my boobs
weigh like 30 for real if you give me a
scale
up from the grocery store i did weigh my
boobs they're literally like 30 pounds
for real for real
yeah so i agree so if you take that out
but also you're not doing yourself a
favor you're like sucking fat at your
stomach injecting in your ass it's like
you just you know you you like the fat
you hold on to it
yeah yeah kitties just like what's it
called the
what's i'm working on i like to
read this yeah thank you redistributed i
feel like you know you just weren't
going to tell me
i was curious how long that was going to
go okay wait are we
hold on hold on we've got two of them
make it happen and tell them it's urgent
okay why does this always go off the
rail i said
when we started we said we both said
we're just gonna do the beauty products
this is not going off the rail and now
we're getting two triple threats
i want this cheese on mine i just like
to play wait i thought we're sharing i
thought it was a conversation no there's
two pizzas so you can get what you want
oh
so each of us get a pizza to our dome
yeah i can eat a whole dan are you
recording this are you paying attention
it is
going right because dan's like over
there ordering pizza we're yanking it up
yeah no no we're not stopping all right
so moses is crouching down he's got his
phone your pizza
you just cheese i'm just cheese but they
got me too they come with two pizzas
why are you getting just cheese why are
you so boring i'm on a diet
you're on a diet pepperoni is more fat i
don't like pepperoni
i'm plain i don't like sauces i don't
like anything i like just plain ass
cheese i do like plain pizza i'll be
honest i'll
take it with olives do you prefer that i
don't think i've ever had an olive i'd
try it
you have never had an olive no for real
dan moses has trisha ever had an olive
okay yes moses why did when
oh you didn't have it actually you've
never had an olive
the texture of it looks weird to me it
looks like it's like green and i don't
know well i
there it comes with black olives oh
yeah no i try it but i like cheese you
never had an olive
okay all right well let's let's pause
while we order the pizza it takes me
it takes me like two one minute i have
the app seriously
um yes can we get two of the triple
treat boxes
sure what's up what kind of crust do you
want for
all of our pizza what kind of crust they
got do they have like cheese packed
what kind of crust that are available we
got cheese pad we gotta get cheese pack
original pan and hand sauce do you have
cheese packed
no we don't okay okay what were the
options again just the original
no what are the options i'm sorry could
you repeat one more time
what's happening like on the first pizza
um okay can we just get
cheese and black olives or
plain cheese on one pizza and black
olives in a second black olives
pineapple and jalapeno are you serious
what the [ __ ] okay so cheese pizza i'm
sorry cheese on just one
okay and then the second pizza jalapenos
black olives and pineapple
what is what i can't order the pizza i
want okay and then for the second triple
treat box can we get one cheese pizza
okay and a veggie
pizza
and what crust options are there
what's the difference between hand toss
and pants we're just gonna get a little
original
oh the thick boy huh
okay we'll just do all original that's
fine thank you she's putting the kai
boss on the dick no problem so
one box is gonna be all cheese one pizza
the other pizza
i want thick i want thick sorry sorry
what i'm sorry
yeah so one cheese and then like
i'm sorry no problem one
box is going to be one pizza cheese the
other one is olive pineapple
thick crust on that one thick crust on
the pineapple one
5805 and it's gonna take about 15
minutes for pick up
okay thank you so much excuse me thank
you okay bye
i i want the thick crust why are you
controlling my pizza order
it's so complicated it's not you go i go
i want olives
pineapple jalapenos seriously i thought
this whole episode was beauty let's get
the beauty products going
that was my objective and now we [ __ ]
thank you moses
let's get do i have you have money to go
i don't have the money on me
no i'll give you a couple bucks when you
get back he's baller
thank you moses you're gonna be broke
after all the diamonds and the pizza
got to keep you whole but it's like an
investment because he's investing now
entire relationship like making me happy
and then long term like
you got to get her you got to get her
fat enough that you could never
date anyone else that's what the feeding
is i think that's what i do to
boyfriends all my boyfriends gain a lot
of weight you just make them
unattractive to anybody else
you know what automatically makes
someone unattractive so everyone else is
like when like
dating me they're like wow like you were
like
look i don't have any money will you
take the bag moses and i had to fight
anime over here but now we're you did
what'd you guys fight about
i had a fight i've been talking about my
chemical romance makeup it comes out
tomorrow
you're fighting about my chemical
romance makeup collection i'm not
interested
he just doesn't listen to me and he's
like today why today he's like wait they
have a makeup coming out
i'm talking about my chemical romance
makeup for like a week and i was like
how did you not hear me anyways it's
fine it's not a big deal i love you and
i'm so sorry
you're picking up the pizza i will
literally give you like anything you
want i'm sorry
thank you i feel bad like i don't like
when he like does stuff for me because
he does too much for me
and now i feel like he's doing this and
i feel like it's just too much but
i do it's just picking a pizza he gets
to drive a rolls-royce on the way it's
sick
okay he does out so much and i literally
do nothing for him and i feel so bad but
i'll just
do something what does that mean you'd
like sexual favors
you said i'll do something for you
tonight we don't use sex as a bargaining
chip
in our relationship that's so weird huh
i'm yelling just diamonds yeah smells
like i much prefer sex than diamonds
all right thank you thank you moses we
love we appreciate that a lot all right
let's do the
view and then you held yourself back i
was gonna say we love you for getting
the pizza
wow you didn't though why that's so
weird cuz i felt like that was
like ironic praise and i did want to say
that
yeah i did want to show sincere
appreciation
let's do some beauty products while we
wait for the pizza now there's just the
pizza episode
let's fill in the void yeah thank you
you said give me ideas and i got one the
pizza episode
all right all right binging with babish
on here i want to cook with him
let's focus okay i just think we should
do more food related stuff
also sponsors you said we don't get
sponsors we should get like erectile
dysfunction like those kind of people
like trojan comet
trojan condoms would be awesome like
people i see people do eating
like reads all the time yeah we have
some idi reads on our other
on our main why can't they sponsor us
food fast food fast food i mean
okay let's [ __ ] it okay so we are doing
today celebrity beauty
product or no no specifically
beauty facials right no it's all over
the place
okay okay all over the map this is what
celebrities do and the freakish
celebrities who like
basically they've got nothing better to
do they've tried everything and so that
that's when you like
eat drink baby blood so this is kind of
where we're at
that's what we're doing we're not
drinking baby but like we're in that
stratosphere of like desperate to try
anything to thrill yourself so if we're
still gonna we're gonna start by
freshening
up kate hudson says that
um she dips her face in ice water
every morning that's what we're starting
with because
it reduces it it reduces inflammation
and swelling in the face
okay lady um should i have my earrings
these are like
20k they get wet i don't know you can't
get diamonds wet yeah i guess you can
i think they just lose yeah you can you
can shower with them i don't okay fine
we'll do it
wow you got the big ass one this ice
kind of looks weak though like
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding
i have a size eight like a men's fitted
cap i'm like a size eight and a half i'm
so i don't have a big head no you're not
because it's rude
i just said it because you have a big
bowl i didn't mean to no you can't
do you have a big head i don't know i
haven't measured it but that's like you
gotta get one of those dome measures to
be like
i'm triggered because i do have a big
head i'm sorry i don't think you can't
make fun of someone who actually has
something wrong with them like i can't
be like oh
you know you know what i mean i don't
know whatever no i know what you mean
i'm sorry
all right let's dunk our heads ready one
two three
it's so cold [ __ ] this oh damn you went
for a girl okay i gotta go harder
it feels wrong you're supposed to go for
as long as you can
yes helps with inflammation helps with
swelling beautiful beautiful
you guys should make it a competition
actually who could hold it oh my god
it's so cold it feels awful
at the same time i hate it i won this
challenge it feels tight though
i was in the ice bath the longest so i
can win you wanna do it do you wanna go
the longest well it's really a
breath holding competition more than
anything i'm not thinking that too i was
like why am i out of breath
you wanna do a competition you just
wanna sit silently for a minute with our
head and ice let's go
all right here we go okay three two one
go
all right both looking steady so far
it's so cold it hurts it doesn't hurt
it's just more the breathing
no the breathing i can hold my breath
for 10 seconds
you nudged me can we do it without him
no i'm not doing it again
it's good for your skin i do actually
feel better because my skin's really bad
it's so cold but yeah it does tighten it
certainly tightens that's what cold does
it's like yeah if you put liquid
nitrogen on your face it'll tighten your
skin
that's what cold does yeah you're
supposed to wash your face with cold
water because it does that
we should sit in an ice bath and see who
last longest because i feel like i would
lose
you win are you someone that's always
hot
i mean i always wear shorts everywhere
no matter what like i'm always hot like
last night
i think you run hotter than me though oh
i'm like sweating when people are
freezing with jackets on i'm like
no it's firing i'm such a i don't think
it's because i'm fat i think you just
have a
sweating problem okay well i hated that
take this
you don't want it i mean i did i do i do
feel kind of good
damn this girl can't get enough of the
ice dunks
she's in there she's got her face
submerged it feels good like it does
feel like i'm like
tightening my face like this feels like
botox right now it's like numb
your mascara is running down your face
looks like a good it looks like a you
know what i mean
i feel like emo i kind of feel like my
chemical i feel good i'm not gonna lie
it's not a bad way to start your day
what's the worst thing i feel pretty
refreshed
oh my god wow i look good okay cool i'm
feeling tightened
what's next okay so moving on is
brushing your teeth
well this is the morning routine
apparently [ __ ] me with a toothbrush
you remember that video
no that's classic youtube tana tana
mangu
yeah what did you say he [ __ ] me with
a toothbrush that's her classic
her most popular video is the story time
he [ __ ] me with a toothbrush
oh i don't watch her i don't watch her
it was like seven years ago so
i don't like her at all do you like her
she's just like i don't understand why
she won like creator of the year i
thought that was so awesome
but it's all like set up right i mean
it's just based on how many people you
can beg to vote for you so that's why i
always thought it was dumb
oh well hopefully you think you'll win
this yet the stream
no no never what is this okay so we're
doing a brush routine we're gonna brush
our teeth but we're gonna start with
catherine zeta jones she's
she brushes with strawberries which is
weird because what
i mean look i'm pretty into dental
hygiene and i pretty much sure that you
shouldn't
spread sugar around into the deepest
crevices of your mouth what's the
benefit of it though like whatever so
the benefit is that
apparently the acid the acid could uh
help clean off your teeth
she says zetta jones sweetens her daily
teeth brushing
regiment by using crusted crushed
strawberries
i was told it's a natural whitener it
really works for me anyway strawberries
taste better than most toothpaste she
said yeah
you're not supposed to [ __ ] eat we
just eat it i want to eat it it looks
good
the doctor said um doctor said
malic acid in strawberries is dangerous
for your teeth
the acid can wear away the enamel people
used to suck on lemons
and they would get a clean feeling but
it would wear away the teeth's natural
enamel so what is this though the orange
this is another one
we're doing the strawberries we're doing
the strawberries first all right so
catherine zetta jones who has apparently
rotted t you see her smile she's like
hey well you know all these slippers
just get fake teeth so it's like okay
lady do you have fake teeth
what does it look like no you're nice
though i don't either but i want veneers
i think they look nice i just yeah i
think they look good too but like
i think it's if you don't need them it's
a whole pain in the ass right like if
one breaks
they literally file your teeth down like
there's no going back i wouldn't do that
i wouldn't do that unless my mouth was
like mega [ __ ] and i was like all
right
i agree i agree okay okay i'm gonna
brush my teeth with
sugar normal like just like brush back
and forth cheers yeah
gross i hate it there's like baking soda
in here too
yes oh i hate it i can't eat or no
i'm sure you can i would i wouldn't you
could eat that this is strawberry and
baking soda
yeah but she's gonna be eating some
other stuff i don't know
okay i'm done
gross disgusting
there's a cup there to spit in don't
have water i just have coffee
yeah um wait what to do like
it's not about what to do like what's
the big benefit she says it's supposed
to whiten your teeth
but i think i mean look there's products
you know they look lighter
scientists have figured this out
honestly the colgate people are on that
[ __ ]
i do need it white and does it whiten
for real
it's just a strawberry no
i mean but she's a [ __ ] idiot she's
clearly a dumbass
like colgate is like we have the biggest
scientists chemists in the world who are
formulating all the recipes to whiten
your teeth and catherine's ed jones is
like
no strawberries no you know what the
beauty
a fake beauty hack on tick tock and i
want people to know that this is they're
trying to sabotage you for real
the dove soap they say if you have
really bad acne this is how my acne got
out of control i had kind of bad acne
but then it became severe after i tried
this beauty hack
they say all you need is a dove soap
it's a big trend on trick talk like just
dove soap that's it horrible advice
don't use anything else so i used it for
a week i have a tic-tac and i didn't
finish it because my skin was breaking
out so
oh my god bad from it and someone loves
soap what's the genius thing i think
dove was promoting it as like oh [ __ ]
as like um like an acne cure-all and
then um
it made it worse and so when i went to a
dermatologist because my skin was it's
still
crazy right now they were like oh it has
so much wax on it that it's like the
worst thing to put on your super
perfumey and it's like really heavy i
don't think it's good for your face like
i literally
try to do it and then like my follow-up
i'm like it's still awful like i can
show you the draft i didn't want to so
that backfired i wonder if everyone's
like we're breaking out dub soap is
ruining our lives like it wasn't that
bad there and then you'll see well i
mean it's kind of like it's kind of like
long but it wasn't like
horrible oh [ __ ] it's too long but then
i used it like for like four days and my
skin was just
like it was craters on my face like it's
been so bad i mean don't use hand soap
to wash your face i feel like
that common knowledge no i think you can
like dial soap is supposed to be really
good on your face i mean some people i
mean
you know what my dermatologist told me
when i was a kid he says use your
shampoo to wash your face because
shampoo is lighter
and less has less impact on your face
than soap and so i always use my shampoo
or not always with some
yeah some because sometimes i use face
wash but it's too heavy and it dries out
my skin so i do it like once a week oh
you missed it it was so bad anyways but
anyway a dermatologist told me use your
shampoo
once it's in your hair to wash your face
and it's a gentle good wash
um i don't know about that i don't know
i use so much now i went to like a witch
doctor the other day and i
have like all these potions i've been
using and it really did clear up my skin
like i mean my skin's a little bit
shampoo i don't trust that are you
willing to [ __ ] try witch doctor
witchcraft it was literally witchcraft
instead of shampoo
right she zapped my pimples and they all
just like disappeared and i was like and
she like zapped it with smoke did she do
it
did she do a chant why are you wearing
murder gloves av thank you though
wait ap okay nevermind you're being safe
i i appreciate it
was it true that you're a fan of the
show and that's how you got this job
like
not our show h3 yes that's a quick
version of it yeah really that's crazy
cool
same with ian and zach wait really i'm
scared to hire people that like
watch me you know well it was yeah i
agree but it was a very careful uh
process it's cool no it's awesome that
you like ian was kind of a mole he
pretended like he was a fan and then we
realized recently that he actually his
brother was the fan right
but that's okay we love you sometimes
it's the opposite they pretend like they
don't know who you are but they're like
a huge fan
um but evie's cool you know he's not
like no exactly
and they're like dorky you think they'd
watch h3 but like av looks cool like why
would you
well interestingly enough abs probably
the biggest sim he's like a mega h3 cent
a simp yeah yeah that's what the
internet labeled me what's a sim he made
like a whole video defending me and [ __ ]
like
an hour long video it's a simple
simpleton somebody who's like a
uh they they're like you know you never
heard sim
that's what it stands for no it's uh
sucker
what is it sucker uh
idolizing what it's like it's a sucker
idolizing mediocre [ __ ]
i feel like they added that it might be
them afterwards yeah
but i'm why don't i have senpai
i think you're i think i think you would
have to be to pay for your only fans
really yeah where's my sims they're out
there
sure anyway he yeah i want to say he's a
mega fan dude
god bless him that's crazy you look so
cool are you still a mega fan now that
you like know me
yeah nice oh you like made a video
defending ethan yeah like an hour long
video
wait why just vs youtube drama
okay you were like adamant against his
opponent was it keemstar was it that
situation or something else keemstar was
perpetuating it but
no it wasn't it wasn't bad i like people
like that though like i like hardcore
people but to be fair i also learned he
almost made a video attacking me about
michael jackson
no no it wasn't attacking you it was an
attack it wasn't a front no no no it had
nothing to do with you but
but the guy i was going to do it with
was uh
anti-aging yeah wait were you going to
make it with with who
well he didn't want to be a part of it
but he was like helping me like
structure it
i'm like we were going to make a video
against j station uh
oh who's g station yeah another youtuber
i'm worried in two deep let's go
can't watch the h3 podcast you guys talk
about like who are they talking okay
whatever
turmeric time do you want to talk eric
this is tomato
okay okay so here we have i gotta rinse
this off
i'm just gonna i guess i didn't mind it
if it makes my teeth white or honestly
you're just rinse it in your water no
i'm going to drink my water i planned on
it too but like [ __ ] happens dude
i'm fine i'm not a little [ __ ] like you
i'm not you you're not suppose
you're not supposed to mix the
strawberry with the tumeric it ruins the
experiment
you're like an anti-simp for me i'm just
trying to figure out simpson so you're
like you're not a sent from me right
because
i'm not an anti-simp i'm your friend an
anti-simp would be someone who's like i
hate that person
you said that on the sibo podcast you
said you considered him best friends and
i always say we're not friends
because like people are like are you
friends right now because we don't like
i couldn't call you
address friends no because i consider
friends when you call okay what do you
consider me
um like co-workers we're co-workers
okay whatever yeah because you make me
money and like you know what i mean
you're kind of like
it's like boss kinda
i'm your boss because you like control
the money you're like you're gonna get
45
and none of the highlights and i'm gonna
pay you and i want and like this is what
we're gonna do so you kind of tell me
what to do but at the same time i like
it because i control everything else in
my life so i kind of like just showing
up and like you already have this plan
i'm not complaining also i think that's
contagious whatever
your symptom is where i think i have
that now too it's not contagious
what is it it's just curd i have a gerd
i think now too it's not contagious
i start doing that now too i'm like
that's i don't know why you're doing
that but
it's not for me oh that sneeze like
injured my throat
is herpes contagious uh no i don't think
so you get it from bree
what did you really ask me that i'm
saying like if you had it could i get it
or no we'd have to have sex so it's skin
to skin
skin to skin everyone who keeps me out
of my herbs i'm like i don't even know
how you get herpes like
then you probably have it you probably
do have herpes but it's like
itchy right cold sores around your
vagina no
i've gotten a canker sore in my mouth
once and i thought i was a herpe but my
doctor told me it wasn't
sores are everywhere it's like a white
little dot and i had it i thought it was
a herpe but he said it's a kangaroo oh i
like
seriously damaged my [ __ ] throat
can you next episode like not wear teddy
fresh like one episode
sure okay it's like so a lot okay
ready what's this do what's this america
do you okay
yeah for real i'm okay okay it's
happened before where i sneeze really
hard and then
it takes a minute to recover were you
ever bulimic
no okay tumeric
this one comes from julianne hugh which
i i don't know who she is
q is that julian huff
that doesn't look like huff h-o-u-g-h
yeah that's tough oh
let me see a picture of her let me see
this idiot she's a mormon
look at these these people are so dumb
okay why aren't mormons always
attractive like why are they so pretty
fun type ugly mormon there's not such a
thing
watch i'll find you as some ugly ass
mormons look at the book of mormon i
knew some ugly mormons growing up really
yeah in ventura yeah there's no mormons
in ventura
there's an ugly that's from the book of
mormon dan
like it's supposed to be right maybe
there's not well if they're all
beautiful
so hold on hold on if they're all
beautiful does that
not indicate that the mormons are right
because god's like these people
they're the chosen ones yeah i've seen
plenty of ugly jews
jews are traditionally unattractive
traditionally
conventionally i don't know tumeric
julienne huff
dumbass i've actually been trying
tumeric she told
e you would think it would be the
opposite and it'd stain your teeth but
it actually makes them whiter turmeric
is the bomb y'all should try it
although evidence of its teeth whitening
properties is only anecdotal studies do
show that it brings oral health benefits
to other natural remedies
and other over-the-counter remedies
don't um wait so you eat this are you
just putting on your teeth think you
just brush it you're brushing with it
yeah
but you're doing it with the strawberry
why are you doing that i want to get
extra white
but that's not the point of this it's
it's a little strawberry on there it's
not like gonna
affect it that much gross awful
can you see is it oh i
see it yeah eating cheetos
i don't think this whitens bro i take
turmeric supplements
and it turns my piss like gatorade
yellow
a lot you didn't like the gatorade
yellow piss anecdote
do we eat it or do we just spread it i
think they're gonna fail oh no you
you try to eat it you don't get it i
record but
good luck putting that down how'd you
get this
go to the bathroom i go to the bathroom
i have to do it on camera
okay just eat it it's fine it doesn't
taste that bad don't be a simp
do i use it right okay it's not bad
honestly just swallow it it's actually
not that bad yeah you have a spit one
yeah don't waste a good one that's not
bad
that's why we get the pizza after it's
like a reward oh
that's what my piss looks like you're so
sweaty
i take turmeric supplements because it's
good for like your
digestion of some [ __ ] i don't
nutritionist told me to take it
and it turns my piss like radioactive
yellow it's crazy maybe that's not good
for you
it's just a spice for an episode you
want to go to my lip injection shadow no
no no they're temporary and bloody
temporary they dissolve i don't want to
do that i don't want to do that i hate
that i don't want it
why do you want to inject my lips you
think my lips are inadequate get some
botox like be me for a day get some
botox with some lip injections get some
glam
go buy a 20 000 bag or something you
know what i mean
i do i'm not gonna lie i do think that's
a funny idea you should totally
but i hate the idea of getting botox but
at the same time i
do acknowledge that it's funny so it
would be you know what botox is less
invasive than lipstick because
i'm not getting away from six weeks not
filler right botox then
well that's talking about a physical
filler no matter but i get you
botox will like both go away i feel like
ones
you should get them like right here so
your eyebrows are like this and we go
because
i think you look good i'm really torn on
this
because i hate the idea but it does
sound funny get a 20 000
bag yeah get some botox that'd be so fun
just a day out on the town together yeah
great i would love it maybe post well we
have to wait until the pandemic's over
oh to do something yeah to go shopping
and stuff
that store's open now i'm not doing it
now
[ __ ] both talks everyone hated that i
had uh like powdered sugar on my lips
now thank you baby do you have anything
on my lips this time yeah you have a ton
of turmeric
why what did you tell me you just gonna
let me go well
i don't think those are ever yeah it
didn't help at all yeah
but well yeah was watching
why didn't you tell her that she had
powder on her lips i was like
i mean i i was staring at it the whole
time so
mean but on my screen it just looked
like a glint on your lip gloss
in the beginning i said you have powder
on your lips but then you didn't get it
all off and the whole episode was just
staring at can we have eel as a guest on
our podcast
no why because people think like i hate
her she doesn't like me or something
like i feel like we need to have like
because like you know what i mean like i
like elisa she could sit in yeah she
could probably sit in
you just said no now you're like just a
snap judgment
she's busy don't talk about ela we're
cutting this part out she doesn't want
to be talked about
are you [ __ ] serious i'm serious we
have to cut this
that's [ __ ] crazy like what's even
the point we talked about because she
doesn't like that you're always bringing
her up and saying how
she doesn't like you and all this [ __ ]
because it's not true and she finds it
annoying because
she doesn't want people to start
thinking that like she doesn't actually
like you
well she doesn't well whatever just cut
it out then
[ __ ] i'm serious i'll talk about it mine
i don't care because that's so [ __ ]
i'm gonna stop talking about my personal
life altogether then too
okay whatever and then turn the hp
podcast on boring and i'll just go down
the tubes and no one will care because
you guys are not honest and open about
[ __ ] so
you cut everything out that's personal
i'm sorry whatever
wow you can't even like mention her we
mentioned her last episode because you
every okay you know what leave it in no
every time no don't you go why does ela
hate me and she's like i don't hate her
it's super annoying why does she keep
saying that
and it's causing me like just text you
be like hey i don't hate you
you know what i mean like but when she's
like telling yourself about moses
because i always say
yeah we should cut this let's just move
on no but like in general like
just i'm telling you now like she needs
to text me and just be like hey i don't
hate you you know but it's like
she's telling moses like oh she says i
think that okay this is all off
but i think she's just really annoyed by
the situation and she just needs some
time
what's the situation that i not anything
to do with you with moses
what'd he do
he like is always
honestly it has nothing to do with you
okay and i don't want to get in the
middle of it
but it's between him and her but she
literally brought me up because i was
like we were watching tick tock and i
saw the thing being like at 1 am in the
morning she was like
what are you telling trisha like why is
she saying this stuff on the podcast
like all this stuff oh like
yeah because you well okay she was
irritated because you're like i'm not
inviting mom
and she's like dude why like my mom
doesn't need to see that and i know
but then she's but it's like moses why
are you telling her
that you're not close to us and that
you're not close to your mom and you're
not inviting your mom
talked about moses on the podcast well
before we started this one but it's not
true
and he's not public he's you guys are
talking about him and [ __ ]
whatever it's so fake and that's why h3
is not what it was because you guys are
fake as [ __ ] and cut things out okay
you're
you're like on a thing now i'm not i
just think it's so fake it's so [ __ ]
it's like oh let's talk about it
not to be included and i'm respecting
your request then i'm not talking about
anything personal anymore
okay i don't want to talk about moses i
won't talk about me like it's just
whatever who cares should we well like
that's important cut it i haven't cut
all of it i literally couldn't kill us
i'll just keep going
why are you so upset it's just so
[ __ ] you guys are such [ __ ] you
guys are so fake and it's like
like actually annoying why is it fake
that ella doesn't want because you're
like don't get in the middle of it but
then it's also i see that it's about me
and that my name's brought up and it's
like okay if my name is
it's not about you it's about between
ila and her brother
why do you need to get involved in that
in that dynamic just let them sort it
out
how is that fake but now you're like
don't talk about ela even though we can
talk about emotions
everybody we talk about no she doesn't
like that you every episode we have the
same conversations
we have the same conversation every
episode where you say ila doesn't like
me
doesn't ever say hi i was like hey can
we have her as a guest and then like cut
all that actually she doesn't want to be
talked about period oh okay she's too
good for this podcast all right cool
i don't give a [ __ ] no because i know
she does she needs some time
okay cool i'm away from all this great
and you go i
i came in you you start off always by
saying i came in and eli didn't greet me
and she was super rude and he was like
that's [ __ ]
you say that about me too and you go she
goes that's [ __ ]
i'm always nice to her i like her the
whole thing is stupid
and people are going to start and she
never said she was rude to me ever
you say she doesn't greet you nicely
i've never said that about ela ever i've
said that about you i've never said that
about ela
find that find them on the tape like i
hate when you say that stuff just like
last episode you always say it i can
tell you it's not true the episode and
you never find it and then you just
glaze over it you're like you did say
that show me where i said that in a
video anything i never said that once
about ela
like that's [ __ ] i hate when you put
that [ __ ] in my mouth like that's so
stupid
i feel like you always you just did it
now you talk about how she doesn't like
you and he was like i like her i don't
want
her to keep saying that [ __ ] tapes i
said have her as a guest on because
people think she doesn't like me and
that i don't like her
and that's not true and that's why i
think she should be on and then you're
like cut that we can't talk about her oh
okay she's too [ __ ] good for this
podcast cool
love that
[ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] leave it i
don't care i've got it all out who cares
i just keep on with this
i don't care like i don't care and
that's why i don't like i'm not
comfortable coming in this house because
like i'm like i'm not sure how to
respond because i feel like you're
having a
you're having like a you're having like
a
yeah let's just move on then talk about
it anymore you're the ones that talk
about it okay
let's move on you want to move on for us
okay it's not like that
you guys can chat off the show even
though i'm on the [ __ ] h3 podcast
channel for you guys getting you guys
more views overall more subscribers
overall you guys are getting 300 000
views this summer so [ __ ] off
oh but i'm too good don't talk about me
even though you're on my [ __ ] channel
so you are taking credit for the
renaissance of the asian podcast for
sure
you guys of course i thought this summer
it was [ __ ] tanking but oh and i'm on
this and people are
subscribing people say i see it all the
time not saying i'm the like the
whatever but people oh i came here
because of trish like i found it because
of course i bring a new audience to this
channel
so it's like but oh but i'm too good for
it to be talked about even though i do
[ __ ] h3 podcast channel you're
literally taking
like something way out right here
honestly and then not in this house like
i feel uncomfortable coming here
i don't know what to do because you're
having like a moment i'm not i'm like
honestly can just move on from it but
like
i just hate people who think they're
just too [ __ ] good for [ __ ] it's not
she's too good
she has a [ __ ] podcast when you have
a podcast you're talked about your
life's talked about you guys talked
about moses
dude well before we did this podcast you
guys talked about us
never once asked me anything no it's
because you always make the same comment
about her
one thing this summer or when we start
dating you never but you guys talked
about that i don't even know what you're
on about
does all this she just doesn't want you
all she's not too good [ __ ] mention
my name meanwhile you guys can talk
about whoever you want you guys talked
about me all spring when i without you
you can talk about whatever you want too
she just doesn't like that you always
come on and say make the same comment
she's not a [ __ ] private figure she's
like no but you you guys are family it's
different
no [ __ ] you're you're you're with her
brother i won't come back here like if
you want me i know you guys own the
[ __ ] building too but like i'm not
gonna come back in this house because
i'm so over it
she has a [ __ ] podcast she's a
publisher what about you surprise [ __ ]
about us
like i'm so [ __ ] over it dude it's
not like that
but it is you guys oh you guys had free
reign to talk about especially me you
guys even contacted me you guys were
talking to moses but not me and talked
about me all spring my relationship it's
a family issue
it's a family issue it's between moses
and ela
yeah okay cool great why don't you
believe and it was between me and moses
this spring but you guys had a [ __ ]
chime in about oh i don't like it that's
what she said and when moses
i don't like it i don't like when moses
asked me not to talk about it we stopped
talking about it guys didn't
yes we did after the time when we showed
the text
between like all this is gonna be cut at
some point it's so pointless i don't i
literally don't care cut it don't give a
[ __ ] don't give a [ __ ] about you guys
like i literally don't care
men moses doesn't like you and you guys
don't like him and that's cool obviously
that's happy that you can't
that's stupid but it's true it's just
well that's [ __ ] up that's the kind of
that's the kind of [ __ ] you say that
makes ila mad because you go moses
doesn't like you
and so what you're doing what you're
doing is you're causing problems in
their family
and that's [ __ ] up because you told me
that she doesn't want any more though
it's like what the who the [ __ ] are you
[ __ ] what did she say she said
i read it i saw it because i was on
[ __ ] tick tock yeah maybe you
shouldn't read his private [ __ ]
message talk and there's a message that
comes up and i see
i'm not reading it i see it yeah no
you're reading his private messages with
his sister you shouldn't do that
unless he shares it with you and he does
okay so what did he say
so what does she say we're not even
talking about it it's not it's look
exactly this is what she doesn't want
being brought up i'm i'm not gonna
[ __ ] she's not talking about you
she's having a conversation with her
brother
all right cool and then we'll just move
on
yeah i think we should move on we have
pizza on the way you're gonna you're
gonna
you're just gonna forsake all the pizza
i don't want to like come back here for
real like to the house because i
don't feel comfortable it's her house
like i don't want to be in here
you don't want to eat the pizza we can
finish this episode but like i'm just
telling you
are you still excited for the pizza
right yeah i can't wait
that's sarcastic i'm still excited for
the pizza
can we move past this when i have a kid
i'm not gonna have nannies that's pretty
i'm sure
what does that mean you're not gonna
have a babysitter when you have a kid
how are you gonna do anything
you're gonna what does that mean you're
trying to attack our parental
abilities let's just move on
there's no attack i just made it there's
something wrong with having a nanny in
my eyes yes
really what about daycare
daycare is different why daycare
is nannies are like people who come here
and take care of your child
all day because we're working that's how
everybody has nanny they work people
work
and take care of kids and work i never
had a nanny my my parents i never had a
nanny
and so you think we're bad parents
that's what you're insinuating i said i
would never have a nanny did i say you
had a
parent you're putting words in my mouth
i literally said i would never have a
nanny if i had a kid
okay well i think a lot of people have
nannies a lot of our employees have
nannies
because we both work right and so we
have a nanny that theodore really likes
and he spends the whole day with her and
then when she's done around 4 30 we take
over and spend
i think that's pretty normal happy for
you guys
why are you attacking our parental i'm
not i said i would not have a nanny if
it was me
but but i'm not attacking your printer
choices you do whatever you want
not technical but why did you make that
comment then i'm just saying i heard
nanny upstairs and i was like oh i just
i want to have a nanny why'd you say it
because i want to have a nanny i heard a
nanny upstairs
but clearly trying to say something
about us no i'm not at all that's you
really you just said it out of nowhere
when you're mad at me and you're
projecting that
no i'm not why would i how am i
projecting
because you're like oh you're attacking
me like you attack you i just i don't
know
you think i'm a good dad it was a
comment i have no idea i never i don't
know you seem fine you seem good with
him i have no idea if you're a good dad
i can't say either way
but i have a nanny yeah that's a problem
i don't think it's a problem i would
just you know if i was lucky enough i
don't know i would just spend my time
with the kid
and figure it out where we could you
know figure it out because my mom and
dad did that my mom was a single mom
and we still never had a nanny she
didn't work when you were like one and a
half
she worked at night and nobody watched
you my brother
oh well he doesn't have a brother or a
sister so should he just be by himself
have family don't you you can't be with
his grandparents he's they're they're
not here
they have a livestream i wish they had
alive i would let them come that's what
family
grandma watched me okay so then this is
the problem with my family
sure put that out there if that's the
narrative you want to say sure
whatever you want me to say i will if
you want me to say that i'm just trying
to follow the thread because you're
upset and you're trying to
i literally made a comment that if i'm
lucky enough to have kids because i
can't [ __ ] have kids and i'll be with
them all the [ __ ] time and make sure
i can spend as much as i can with them
and then don't you think it's healthy to
be away from them sometimes
yeah but they should be with another
family member so they should never be
with anyone that's not in their family i
don't believe in that at all
seems extreme seems like not everybody
has that luxury
you know sure so should i quit or should
he look quit
it's not about quitting it's about
balancing your schedules in my opinion
you can do whatever you want but if it
was me
would be called balancing your [ __ ]
work schedules especially because then
you're both blessed to be able to like
work for yourselves
like you should i would i would balance
it so right now ela's at the job and i'm
doing the podcast so
you sho so should i not do the podcast
or she should not be at the
i think both i think i just wanted you
to help with my schedule so i'm not
gonna do a podcast
i'll give you a year yeah i'm just
trying to help my help yeah i'm asking
for your help scheduling my life around
theodor
all right so i'm doing the podcast now
so eli should be at home for sure
and then when i'm done with the podcast
she can go to the office and i'll be
with theodore yeah i think that's a
great schedule
okay and do you know what it's like
being with a one and a half year old
it's not because i don't have a parent
it's a little insensitive because i'm
infertile and it's a really issue that i
struggle with i
ask is because you know you realize that
you can't do any work when you're with
that you're saying do you have kids or i
get my face that i don't so
no that's not what i was doing that's
exactly what you're doing because you
know i don't have kids no what would you
do
my point was that you're assuming that
it's so easy for me
to be with the one point one and a half
year old not knowing how insane and like
non-stop
it is that i wouldn't be able to do it
anything else with the rest of the day
when i have work to do i have to work
i'm a i'm an adult i have a job
like most adults do and what happens if
you're two parents and you have to go
like huh your mom and dad don't want to
watch theodore they don't want to
they're here on sundays with him i know
my mom would be like oh let me
like my that's your mom right so i'm
just giving you my perspective you asked
for my help so you're criticizing my mom
you said i gave you my parents no i want
yours yeah i want your perspective
okay that's all i said well i i do wish
you guys have a kid and i'm sure it'll
be
great and i hope that you quit doing
everything you do in life just to be
with that kid
24 7. and you know what that's when you
find someone and i hope moses sister i
hope moses quits every single thing he
does to be with the kid
every single moment when you're on when
you are that's totally fine if he wants
to if he doesn't want to whatever he
wants to do
yeah like everybody does with kids yeah
they quit everything they do
when you have a kid you should try and
be with that as much as possible not
be with the strangers
abby's not a stranger she's not your
family
dan's not i mean dan's not family but i
trust him
okay the pizza's here
wow should we keep doing beauty products
whatever you want all right let's do it
i what triggered you again what were we
talking about you know being too good
for me to talk about on this podcast i
don't even [ __ ] mention her and she's
a [ __ ]
queen like don't even [ __ ] mention me
on the podcast right you know i'm a
literal podcaster
right that's why i'm cool uh oil you
want to do the oil
the pizza's here everybody
the pizza's here we had a full meltdown
while you were gone
expect another text from your sister
i'm not coming back to the house i'm not
i don't know
moses said what happened you know this
is the literal meme where you walk in
with the pizza and the room's on fire
this is the literal meme when you come
back with the pizza oh my gosh
left to get pizza this is literally
she's really upset because she was
saying how ila doesn't like her
ela says don't talk about me in the
podcast all i said was just check out
the guests he's like we can't mention
english she doesn't let me talk about oh
she's too good for a [ __ ] podcast
even though we were talked about they
never once insulted me
she has a [ __ ] podcast i brought life
to the [ __ ] h3 channel but oh he
looks too [ __ ] good to even mention
her name i said nothing bad i said like
oh whichever is a guest or whatever like
that don't even mention anything
we talked about [ __ ] okay i literally
don't care
literally i don't want to come back and
i really [ __ ] hate her
so she she always making comments about
the family and how
i wasn't that wasn't it i said oh ela
should be
on the podcast and you're like don't
[ __ ] mention ela she's the one
talking about oh a [ __ ] queen you
guys can talk about my [ __ ] all the time
but her don't [ __ ] mention her name
dumb [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay i think we should just end it
honestly yeah i think so too
she's such a [ __ ] [ __ ] she's not and
you are too and you're a [ __ ] cop
you're taking no [ __ ] phone all right
you should leave
we'll talk later yeah you should get out
i am going but we're not talking later
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you too
careful i couldn't care less it's not
about
dumping
i don't know what happened you better
just
well if just so you know what happened
we were just she was talking she was
talking about like how you're like my
mom
she says like you your brother hates you
and your mom's not she's like she says
this stuff in passing and it really
upsets ila
so she started saying this stuff and i
said ela asks that we don't talk about
this stuff anymore
so that's it that's all that happened
no i know okay but i'm just telling you
so you know the situation you're dealing
with
all right
well everybody i've been waiting for
this moment for a long time
well hold on okay um
i think we struck a nerve and
i i think
here's here's the best i can summarize
this
without her being here and being fair to
her is that
she always saying stuff about their
family it's more complicated right
because she's
dating her brother and when she says
comments on the podcast like
uh you guys aren't even close your
brother doesn't even like you your mom's
not coming to the wedding and stuff
it caused real problems in her family
and most of all it's not true
right and so elos gets frustrated and
she says can you please stop talking
about the family and talking about me
i need like a break from this [ __ ] and
so she brings up ela
and i says we we're we can't talk about
you
and that's kind of what happened i think
the problem is maybe that
tricia does think that eli doesn't like
her which isn't true
but i do think that they probably need
to work it out
because i ila does like trisha she
watched the last episode and she loved
it and she thought it was great and
you know we we both think trisha is
awesome
and uh i think they just need to talk i
think trish is right eli should have
reached out and said something to tell
her that she doesn't hate her because i
think
you know she doesn't feel comfortable
coming to home because there's like
weird friction
like they left last time and didn't say
goodbye to ila and he was like hey what
happened but
so i understand her emotions you know
and i feel bad that she's feeling really
bad i do feel bad
um so
you know i understand and i feel bad and
i'm gonna try to
to fix it and um
i know what's to say but we didn't stick
to the plan
i really want to stick to the plan this
time and we didn't do it
but the good news is we got pizza a lot
of it
the bad news is that if trisha is not
feeling great right now
that was the worst i've seen her
probably actually even worse than the
last time
i felt really bad for her i did i just
don't know how to help her
when i see her doing that so i don't
know but um
[Music]
i shouldn't go on without her anyway
that's it this
episode and uh we'll see
what happens in the future but uh
i don't know all right thanks for
watching guys
[Music]